well you know my theme of the year of  marriage I'm gonna stick with that right  now look at gold medalist Lindsey Vonn  putting a little spin on tradition  she just proposed to her fiance New  Jersey Devils star PK Subin so they  actually got engaged back in August but  on Christmas she decided to propose with  a ring and she said that we talked about  equality in action men should have  engagement rings - he obviously said yes  she's not the first celebrity to propose  and I know I get it they were already  engaged but Judge Judy Jennifer Hudson  Elizabeth Taylor all proposed as well I  gotta say it's too late for me now he's  got the wedding ring on but Sean grandi  you're lucky because I would have put an  engagement ring on your finger that is  great I'm all about equality but now you  know I mean I still want to get used to  me that part I love but I think it's  good I like the idea of a male  engagement ring